from mantis and drax's Adventures in
Hollywood to a terrified Gavin bacon and
even a special Cameo by Kingo the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
is filled with Christmas cheer and
Easter eggs
Marvel Studios has gotten more creative
with its opening credit sequences in
phase four especially with music cues
eternals replace the typical Marvel
theme with something reminiscent of a
vintage Western Thor love and thunder
puts a power ballad spin on it both
Marvel Studios first ever special
presentation the Halloween special
werewolf by night made the most
significant changes to the status quo
with its new title graphic its black and
white claw slashes and its screams and
howls the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special continues this emerging
tradition with its Christmas themed
opener as a Pogues Christmas song fairy
tale of New York plays the usual comic
Graphics of Marvel superheroes are
interspersed with images of Christmas
trees garlands kids ice skating and of
course a big guy himself Santa Claus
well the werewolf By Night opener enters
some black and white flashes of
lightning the intro of the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special ends with the
words Marvel Studios lit up in red and
green Christmas lights these cheeky
alterations aren't just a nod to the
season Santa is actually part of Marvel
Comics Canon
on the subject of music choices the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
features two live performances by
professional musicians first up
alternative country band old 97s are
decked out in holiday attire they've
been transformed into four different
alien species all of whom are playing
their Earth instruments for the first
time they do this as they try to write a
new song and historical document about
human Christmas everything I know about
Christmas I learned from rocket who
learned from Cosmo who learned from
craglin who learn from you that new song
I don't know what Christmas is but
Christmas Time Is Here is full of
hilarious misinterpretations of
Christmas stories and symbols for
example the alien band thinks that if
children misbehave Santa puts dung in
their socks as opposed to coal in their
stockings which are frustrated Peter
Quill insists isn't part of the lore at
all later Kevin Bacon joins the old 97s
to perform one of the group's
pre-existing holiday numbers here it is
Christmas time
bacon isn't just a movie star in the
subject of the game Six Degrees of Kevin
Bacon he's also a member of the band the
Bacon Brothers alongside his sibling
Michael the Bacon Brothers play a
similar style of country folk rock music
to the old 97s so when this
fictionalized version of the actor
chooses to stay of his own volition to
celebrate the holidays on nowhere he
picks up a guitar and fits right in with
the alien entertainment the holiday
special soundtrack includes some other
fun auditory Easter eggs too like The
Strokes Julian casablanca's rendition of
the Saturday Night Live Christmas song I
wish it was Christmas today
writer and director James Gunn said that
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special will fill in some important
narrative gaps and prepare fans for
volume 3 which is scheduled to Premiere
in May of 2023. those appear to be these
two new facts the Guardians are the
proud new owners of nowhere and mantis
as Peter Quill's half-sister let's start
with nowhere viewers might not realize
that this is where they are when the
special begins but nebula tosses off a
line in which she explains that they've
purchased the world that was once a
Celestial skill from The Collector we
also see nowhere in the background as
mantis and drags fly away this confirms
our tanalea tavan is still alive and
strongly implies that nowhere will be at
least a partial setting of volume 3. by
the looks of it the Guardians have done
a commendable job of rehabilitating the
one-time mining colony and outpost into
a tight-knit community thus beginning to
thrive again as for mantis she's afraid
to tell Peter the truth about their
relationship because she suspects it
might remind him of his awful father ego
and his mother's death at egos hand of
course Peter is thrilled to have someone
he can call family but it remains to be
seen how their kinship will impact the
Guardians going forward
news broke that Maria bakalova had been
casting Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
shortly after her star making
performance and the second Borat movie
though nobody knew in what capacity
while she's expected to play a much
larger role in the film she has a fun
Cameo sized role in two scenes of the
holiday special as a new voice of Cosmo
the space dog Cosmo has appeared in the
MCU before in Guardians of the Galaxy
where the dog is behind glass as part of
the collector's collection Cosmo also
appears in the end credits of volume 2
and what if t'challa became a Star-Lord
the character originated in the comics
where he's male and part of the Russian
Space Program the dog was based on a
real canine space explorer who also
happened to be female with Bulgarian
comedian and actor bakalova's casting
Cosmo has been gender swapped
retroactively rendering a female in a
previous MCU appearances but presumably
she retains the same backstory the
already species diverse Guardians of the
Galaxy can only get more delightfully
absurd with the condition of the abrasi
funny bakalova as Cosmo the space dog
sending mantis and drugs to Hollywood
created a perfect opportunity for James
Gunn and Company to have fun at their
own industry's expense the two most
socially inept Guardians walk
confidently down Hollywood Boulevard in
their search for the hero Kevin Bacon
but they pause in front of the famous
TCL Chinese Theater in a fun Easter egg
the actors who play the two Guardians
have put their real handprints and
signatures in the concrete just to the
right of where mantis and Drax are
standing during their photo session
instead of Chris Evans or Scarlett
Johansson in the Captain America or
black widow suits we see people in
Spirit Halloween quality Avengers
costumes posing for pictures with
tourists
besides Kappa Natasha as an Ant-Man a
Captain Marvel a Thor and a Jack Sparrow
for good measure mantis and Drax must
say that counterfeit Captain America for
the real Steve Rogers which leads to an
embarrassing moment but soon they
realize he's selfie happy MCU fans are a
money-making opportunity and they gladly
snap some group picks before continuing
their quest for the best Christmas
present ever
if you look closely at one Banner in
particular near Hollywood Boulevard it
advertises kingo's latest project in our
world we might still be watching the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
but in the world of the MCU the public
is getting kingo's Christmas a large
vertical billboard marketing the actor
slash Eternal special can be seen on the
side of a building before mantis and
Drax enter the bar Kingo played by kumeo
nanjiani is an immortal being Burton
eternals he's biting his time on Earth
as a celebrity who keeps Reinventing
himself as his own son or grandson so as
not to arouse suspicion about his
eternal youth the mcu's version of Kingo
really enjoys being a celebrity he also
fits mantis drags and nebula's
impression of actors a self-absorbed
Fame Chasers who aren't Heroes he's an
actor he's never actually saved anyone
but actors are repugnant I know this is
because Kingo doesn't show up to help
the rest of the eternals in the climax
of that film
another Easter egg that works with a
multi-layer joke with multiple meanings
is the inclusion of celebrity star Maps
when a drunk mantis and drags come to a
dead end in their hunt for Kevin Bacon
the owner of a souvenir shop overhears a
conversation and offers the alien Duo a
map of the Stars these maps are big
business and Hollywood though they're
not always reliable so the idea that
mantis and drags could use one to find
Kevin Bacon's house is a joke in and of
itself since she lost her money mantis
deploys her powers to steal the map and
the rest of the cash in the woman's
fanny pack a graphic appears on screen
that purports to show the locations of
the residents of a handful of
celebrities there's Queen Latifah John
Cena Arnold Schwarzenegger and a photo
of a young Magpul gosselaire from his
Saved by the Bell days once mantis and
drugs get a Kevin Bacon's house the
house number 1988 is a reference to the
year Peter Quill was taken into space by
yondu star Maps is also a sort of double
entender since the Guardians of the
Galaxy exist in space and frequently
travel between planets due using maps of
various star systems
the Guardians of the Galaxy movies
largely take place in space and many
scenes take place aboard spaceships that
means there are tons of vehicles in the
Guardians movies and most of them are
pretty Innovative and recognizable
designs as well as clever names Peter
Quill started with the Milano named
after the 80s and 90s TV star Alyssa
Milano he upgraded to the Benetar names
for singer Pat Benatar which can be seen
in Avengers Infinity War Avengers end
game and Thor love and thunder the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
introduces the guardian's newest ship
the Bowie named after Rock icon David
Bowie Star-Lord commands his crew to get
Kevin Bacon aboard the Bowie and fly him
safely back to Earth so that they're not
on the hook for human trafficking
anymore but once in the driver and
passenger seats of the spaceship craglin
and Kevin Bacon have a heart to heart
Kevin decides to stay a little longer to
teach everyone on nowhere the meaning of
Christmas the Bowie first appeared in
the comics in 2019 so the holiday
special is simply making the ship
officially part of the mcu's Canon
once everyone starts exchanging gifts
the Easter eggs and the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special get even Wittier
and more self-referential nebula who
isn't exactly known for being warm and
fuzzy gives Rockets a sizeable
rectangular box he opens it to discover
a metal appendage Bucky's arm yes to
which nebula says Merry Christmas she
doesn't want to acknowledge it but this
is an incredibly thoughtful gift not to
mention an expensive one Bucky's most
recent arm was made out of vibranium in
Avengers Infinity War Bucky and Rocket
fight side by side at one point the
former lifts the latter into the air and
they take out their surrounding enemies
with a circular barrage of gunfire
afterward rocket tries to negotiate a
price for Bucky's gun and his arm how
much it again not for sale okay how much
for the um
this call back to an Infinity War also
calls back to the first Guardians movie
in its rocket instructs the newly banded
Guardians to steal a prosthetic leg in
their attempt to break out of prison
when it comes time to put their plan
into action he reveals that he didn't
need the leg he just thought it would be
funny
an older teenage Groot carves little
wooden dioramas to all of his friends
and the Guardians holiday special he
hands out the wrapped boxes and each
member of the Guardians opens that
mantises diorama depicts the beginning
of the live-action part of the special
when the Guardians were standing on a
balcony talking about how yandu ruined
Christmas Peter Quill gets a carving of
mantis and drags chasing a terrified
Kevin Bacon down the street Drax
receives a miniature version of himself
flipping over a police car nebulous
scene recreates the moment everyone gave
Kevin Bacon still under mantis's control
to Peter Quill as a gift in other words
the presence Groot has given his friends
tell the story of the holiday special
that leaves cragland who opens his box
last the ham recruiters carved a small
cragland opening an even smaller craglin
opening an even smaller craglin
the Guardians of the Galaxy films have
given the MCU some of its weirdest
supporting and featured characters and
the wackiest might be taserface this
numbskulled and aggressive space pirate
has been in the comics since 1990 but he
made his MCU debut in Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2. when he tried to Stage a
mutiny and came into conflict with
Rocket Raccoon rocket with Peter Lee
mocks his name to which taser face
infamously replied with a full-bodied
shout it's metaphorical
taser face didn't make it out of that
film alive but he popped up in what if
where in an alternate reality he and
craglin pick up t'challa instead of
Peter Quill we don't see an animated
Tater face in the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special but the character
still gets a shout out as yondu goes
through the garbage can of presents and
decorations that he destroyed and threw
away in a fit of anti-christmas rage we
can see that one package has been
designated for taserface the sloppy
handwriting is likely a clue that young
Peter remembered Tater face and got the
angry ravager something special